you're almost 22 years of age bro what
what were you doing when you were 22. I
had well let's see 22 I was uh wanted
for murder my brother and I were on a
two-year trip on motorcycles around the
country we got jobs as waiters in a
Polynesian restaurant there was this
Chef named Peter and Peter was a horrid
man he hated everybody and everyone
hated him before we started a shift we
would talk about how we would kill Peter
Wong well we dice them up put him in the
wok put some oil in there and just stir
fry him but someone wasn't goofing
around at the end of the season I left I
got on my motorcycle the police came
into the restaurant Peter Wong was
murdered did anyone talk about heart
doing him harm or killing him and oh
haters like yeah all of us we didn't
even know we were wanted for us they put
an APB out on our motorcycles and
looking for us we didn't know this until
we came back and they said yeah they
eventually caught the real bad guys and
it was yes they caught the real ones
don't do that